[Music]
you guys ready to go let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
the robed is broke luke dominate here
with the altar boys YouTube channel and
today we are gonna be camping and
exploring this deserted island welcome
to another episode of the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and today we're doing
another camping video but this time we
are gonna be camping on our very own
deserted island how about that and not
only that we're gonna try to catch
ourselves some dinner and cook it up and
eat it as well and and if we're lucky we
might do a little exploring here see
what we can find on this cool island
alright guys you ready to set up camp it
looks like you already found some food
oh that's a muscle yeah that's a big one
too
yeah you can eat these I know oh there's
one over there and there oh yeah they're
delicious we're going to be boil them up
we steamed alone see this line of grass
that's where the water came up to so we
have got to get above that
I gotta be really careful with the tides
it's about an hour before high tide and
so the tide was coming with us so we
were helped by the tide and we burned up
about 1/4 a tank of gas now going back
will take us more gas if we're going
against the tide so I got to be careful
with that also I've got to be careful
because I've beached my boat right and
the tides gonna go out and leave it high
and dry so I got to watch that as well I
just want to set up the camp real quick
then we're to go out and drop some crab
pots and try to catch some crabs for our
food and I got some fishing rods here
we're gonna try to set that up as well
we've got some deep ish water over here
there's a nice little channel that goes
right within casting distance of the
shore here so this should be a good
fishing spot as well as a good camping
spot let's see what we can do your hand
stopped well it's kind of windy and I
really need to stake this tent down but
these little metal stakes that come with
it are garbage so I'm going to really
quick go make some steaks
well I got the tent up and the boys are
taking a sand bath I think I need to go
catch some crabs so let's pull out the
pots so these are my crab pots I'm
allowed to use two at a time and they've
got this little bait pouch here on the
top and you just put any sort of meat
fish in there I've got some dead shad
all right I got two pots baited up and
you go drop them out I'm gonna go out
about 100 200 yards out there with the
skiff and just chuck the pots in about
four or five feet of water let it so
could tell about dinnertime and then
we'll we'll see what we got in our pots
[Applause]
check it throw it throw there you go I
gotta tell you this boat handles so much
better without all that firewood and
camping gear
all right neat you want to throw one
okay throw it and make sure that this
side goes down that okay you don't want
it to flip upside down okay go for it
check it all right there we go you ready
to go fast
all right I want to do a little bit of
fishing here I brought three surf rods
and a variety of rigs I'm not sure what
will catch it's still really early in
the air it's kind of cold frankly even
though it's really sunny out here it's
like 50 degrees in the daytime 40 or 30
in the night we probably have skates out
here maybe blow toads or puffer fish
spot speckled trout maybe you know
that's things like that we just really
don't know it's early in the year and
it's still kind of cold frankly it's not
ideal but let's see if we can't catch
something so I got a little high-low rig
with these little foam beads and some
long shank J hooks number four whale
tongue lead just kind of the basic setup
you get when you're chucking a rig out
into the bay and you don't quite know
what you're gonna get got some of these
fish bites here and they work good as
bait stops it's keeping your your bait
from flying off the hook that shrimp
will want to come off the hook when you
cast and that little bit of fish bite
will keep it from backing off the hook
[Music]
check it out and I broke the tip off my
rod my very first cast the tip of my rod
broke off and I don't know why love this
rod well it's about four o'clock it's
high tide and I'm gonna let those rods
sit out right there is the tides
changing maybe look at getting the boys
a little snack or something and just
gonna relax a little bit then like an x
marks the spot yep Nathan have you
gotten yourself wet yeah are you gonna
go for a swim
all right time are you going for a swim
all right well it's 55 degrees and the
boys say they want to go for a swim
so we'll see we'll see how they like
that run in there if you put your
lifejacket on it'll warm you up a little
bit you warming up Nathan girls Nathan
told me he needs to use the bathroom I
just told him to go behind those trees
over there the boys are having such a
good time I don't think there's anything
I could say or do to get them back into
that boat we're gonna take it nice and
easy tonight we're gonna cook up some
food try to catch some dinner and
tomorrow we're going to be doing some
exploring the very end of the island way
over there you can see a small grove of
trees apparently there are the ruins of
an old building that's abandoned down
there this truly is a deserted island
and we're gonna go try to see if we can
find the ruins and explore them a little
bit tomorrow we'll see if we got enough
gas to make it down there and and
whatnot but I'm excited well we've been
fishing for about an hour not a bite and
I'm only in about four or five feet of
water I cast out as far as I could and I
didn't quite make it out into that
channel out there so I think I'm gonna
reel in my gear and use the skiff to
drop my bait out there in the channel
and see if that doesn't help
[Music]
[Music]
I am almost completely out of line there
all right I got both those rods in the
deep water we'll let that sit and see if
we do any good and hate you cold buddy
yeah okay let's get you dried off okay
the sun's gonna be setting soon it's
gonna get real cold I think the silver
rod just got a bite it is what whoo yeah
oh we might catch something here all
right time you want to reel in the rods
please we got a shark that was my rod
hold it look at that our first yeah is
that your first shot okay turn around
turn around
okay hey just let him go and as soon as
he's ready to swim off see he's swimming
back che come over bite my foot oh yeah
he's going right under the boat he was
walking back and he was right behind my
foot he's got a nibble B well before he
gets dark I'm gonna set up our sleeping
bags here I bought this tent two years
ago at our sturgeon fishing trip in
British Columbia it's just been a great
little tent it was like 35 Canadian
dollars
these right here are negative tawny bags
from Bass Pro Shop and these right here
are the little kids sighs summer bags
these are like 20 degree 30 degree bags
and I've got one for Nate and one for
Tommy
and I'm gonna stuff those inside the
negative 20 bag
Nathan probably doesn't need that kid
can stay warm in the middle of a
snowstorm Tommy gets cold so easily and
he's a little hesitant about going
camping with me unless I can guarantee
his warmth and so we're bringing lots
lots of bags check out my my camping
duffel bag it says clean on that side
dirty on that side take off your dirty
clothes you shove it in the dirty side
keeps all your clothes organized well
the sun's gonna set in about an hour and
a half so let's reel in the rods and go
check the crab pot see what's going on
there
okay can you retailer get it get it this
is all you you got it pull it up
oh look at that
pull it up Dom pull it grab the net grab
it look at it
we've got crabs throw that overboard all
right sit down to-- oh yep
barely that's a male okay let go let's
see there we go big boy he's the biggest
one all right three tiny keepers all
right you want to go get some more let's
do it bird looking for our boy where is
it Nathan
well we pulled both pots and we got five
keeper crabs and we're gonna have crabs
you guys excited
alright see if you can do it they give
them something to hold on to and they
kind of calm down here why don't you go
ahead and put that in there Mason do you
want to try picking one up all right
let's take it over let's get a fire
started shall we all right we're gonna
go ahead and build a fire but we want to
build it below the high tide mark so
that the next high tide will wash it all
away and it won't kill all this grass
which is important to maintaining the
dune got my blast match here hey boys
have you grab me some wood luckily I
have a bunch of leftover lumber from the
fishing cabin project and the handcar
project so we're having a scrap wood
fire today
[Music]
[Music]
it's really for eating all right get old
V well the tide turned I was meaning to
take the boat out deeper but I got
distracted
wha better start pushing
there you go the Sun is setting the
crabs are steaming the boys are playing
this is good hey you guys cold you want
some hot chocolate okay well I'm gonna
make you some hot chocolate okay just
before bedtime I like to put these
adhesive body warmers on the kids I
can't tell you enough how great these
are as a parent they just throw them in
your bag your kids get cold slap a bunch
of these on them
[Music]
oh my that is looking good right there
oh yeah that is all good okay guys why
don't you tell me what you want and I'll
load up your food okay
hey potato shrimp crab you take that so
eating on it
better yet a poo free muscle you take
that crab right there look at that like
that Oh guy is looking at those stars
look at the clear sky thanks having fun
you ready for bed it's late it's past
your bedtime
yeah take your feet in the air like you
just don't care
naughty feet bring this all up
[Music]
all right
I wouldn't put away the mess kits and
everything and they are sound asleep
those boys just socked out well it's
late and I gotta get to bed but it has
been years since I've seen so many stars
it's crystal clear there's no moon and
no man-made light it's just amazing but
it's late and I gotta get to bed and I
am anxious to see if we can explore the
rest of this island including those
ruins tomorrow so I'll see you guys in
the morning good the boats still here
[Music]
good morning guys
Blackbeard the pirate used to use this
island as a hiding place you know that
like that's true story I think the wind
I think the wind picked up a little bit
[Music]
[Music]
all right I am going to eat some lemon
cake lemon cake bacon sandwich people
[Music]
really good good well I really want to
take the boys and go explore the
abandoned mansion at the other part of
the island but a couple factors have
popped up first off I don't have as much
gas in the tank as I thought I did so
I'm a little worried about getting there
and back with the gas we have
additionally the winds kicking up the
forecast has changed a little bit we've
got about 6 to 11 mile per hour winds
right now and it's supposed to kick up
to 20 in the afternoon I don't mind the
wind normally but with this boat fully
loaded down that makes me a little
concerned so what I'm thinking we should
do is hurry and pack up the boat and
take all the gear back to the car get
some more gas and
and go explore what do you think was
this a cool spot this is a pretty neat
camping trip well let's go get the
crabpot shall we okay okay take the logs
and kick them into the flaming sucker
well I went to go get our pot and it's
gone I also noticed that some of the
other pots in the neighborhood are going
to so I think somebody nabbed our pot I
can see the other boy over there so
he'll get the other one
look at that guy
alright we're let him go now look at
this got a big old Wilkes shell in here
do you need them but they're not very
good
oh we've had to slow down the waves are
getting too big
[Music]
these waves are a bit too much for my
day
there we go you know we've only got
about six to eleven mile-per-hour winds
right now and the waves were a little
bit sketchy right at the end there it
really made me nervous so I don't think
we should be going out when we're
expecting to get up to 20 mile-per-hour
winds this afternoon that just wouldn't
be smart but I really wish we got a
chance to explore that mansion if you
guys would like to see us come back and
explore that mansion make sure to click
that like button and let us know and
then we'll come out here on a calmer day
and give it another try you guys want to
go explore that mansion did you guys
have fun on this campout this is a
pretty cool experience if you guys like
this sort of thing make sure to check
out our camping a survival video
playlist and we put out new videos every
Saturday morning so don't forget to if
you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that bell fight you'll get
thanks for watching
[Music]